ultrasound is one of the most common
tools used to survey the human body by
emitting high frequency tones and
recording the echoes the reflected
sounds combine to form an image that's
both easy to read and much safer than
other forms of medical imaging 3d
ultrasound is a recent development in
medical technology allowing doctors to
observe babies and hearts from all
directions and more accurately diagnose
patients however like many new
technologies there is a complexity and
cost to 3d ultrasound because ultrasound
relies on tiny low volume echoes these
imaging devices can require thousands of
sensors to generate a detailed picture
researchers have developed a new system
that cuts this complexity down to just
one sensor in order to achieve this feat
they used a technique called compressive
sensing compressive sensing involves
using mathematics to extrapolate the
information from one data source into
many different points most do this by
using a coded aperture mask they place
over the sensor coated masks can
actually be found in many high-tech
devices such as space telescopes the
prototype ultrasound mask is an
irregularly shaped piece of plastic with
small dots of varying Heights placed on
the surface when the high-frequency
sound waves hit the plastic small delays
are introduced into the audio the sound
is then run through a computer algorithm
that picks out these delays and
represents them as individual pixels
because the dots are unevenly
distributed across the surface of the
cover rotating the mask allows more
measurements to be performed and help
resolve the object at higher detail
the researchers tested this by
submerging two 3d printed plastic
letters in a small tank of water when
they activated the ultrasound sensor the
letters were able to be picked out of
the data and pinpointed in 3d space
while the sensitivity of the device is
very low compared to current 3d imaging
systems the researchers believe
compressive sensing could bring down the
price of ultrasound equipment and help
doctors around the world
[Music]
you
[Music]